hello world in this video I'll be
introducing interval notation and talk
about some common sets this will lay the
foundation for the next video on set
builder notation the beauty of interval
notation is that allows us to
efficiently describe all numbers between
two values suppose we wanted to say that
the variable X is between 0 & 1
well we can do just that we could say
that X is an element of 0 the interval 0
1 or which is really saying X is greater
than 0 and X is less than 1 likewise if
we wanted to say that X is greater than
or equal to 0 and X is less than 1 then
we have to switch this to a square
bracket all we're doing is we are now
including the number 0 in the interval
also we can include 0 and we can also
include 1 in the interval by using
square brackets on both sides so it's
greater than or equal to and less than
equal to and now I'll talk about some
common sets the first one being the null
set which is the same thing as the empty
set which is just there are no elements
contained within the set and this will
come in handy in the future the funny
end here is the natural numbers which is
the set containing elements 1 2 3 and
then these 3 dots here are called an
ellipsis which tells us that the pattern
continues so n is the set containing 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 all the way up to infinity
this funny end with a 0 is the natural
numbers however it includes the value 0
within the set so it's 0 1 2 and in the
ellipsis tells us all the way to
infinity in an integer fashion 0 1 2 3 4
5 6 and finally we have all the integers
positive and negative and non negative
which is 0 negative 1 negative 2 all the
way down negative infinity and 0 1 2 3 4
all the way up to infinity